chers
présidenti madame la secrétaire général
de notre mouvement
chez Rachida Dati qui porte à Paris nos
idées et notre espérance chers amis
c'est un immense plaisir d'ouvrir
aujourd'hui ces états généraux de notre
famille politique merci d'être venu si
nombreux merci
à Éric Ciotti notre président pour le
challenge qu'il a relevé merci à nos
trois présidents de groupe Bruno
retaillod Olivier marlex et
François-Xavier Bennani
merci à tous nos responsables je vois
ici Xavier Bertrand Michel Barnier avec
beaucoup de plaisir et je voulais le
saluer
[Applaudissements]
merci à nos adhérents qui tous
comprennent à quel point nous avons
besoin de nous retrouver
nous voilà engagés sur la voie de la
reconstruction
elle commence me semble-t-il dans le bon
ordre d'abord le débat sur le fond sur
les idées sur ce qui structure notre
engagement politique
comment pourrait-il en être autrement
dans la situation dans laquelle se
trouve notre pays
notre pays va mal et nous vivons dans
une sorte d'insouciance
persuadée que l'État peut tout que tout
finit par s'arranger et que cela
pourrait durer éternellement ainsi
il n'est plus possible de détourner le
regard comme nous l'avons fait si
souvent et depuis trop longtemps
et à chaque fois bien sûr pour de très
bonnes raisons
oui
il faudra rembourser les 3000 milliards
de dettes que nous avons accumulé
c'est de la souveraineté de la France
dont il s'agit oui
[Applaudissements]
oui il faudra repenser un État
providence dont la dépense publique
atteint plus de 1500 milliards et 58% de
notre produit intérieur brut
les agences de notation ont envoyé un
signal à la France c'est un
avertissement que nous devrons prendre
au sérieux
la réponse du gouvernement c'est
l'annonce d'une progression de nos
dépenses publiques de 20000 milliards
pour les 5 ans à venir c'est à mes yeux
consternant alors comment ne pas être
inquiet et pourtant et pourtant
je me refuse à me résigner au déclin
annoncé comme je refuse de céder au
chimères populistes irresponsable de
l'extrême gauche comme de l'extrême
droite nous sommes mes chers amis
nous sommes au Républicain le point
d'équilibre nous sommes l'opposition
responsable celle du pragmatisme qui
refuse le sectarisme et l'idéologie
celle qui croit au redressement de la
France et à son avenir nous sommes
l'opposition qui appelle un programme de
réforme ambitieuse qui permettent
d'engager enfin la France sur une pente
vertueuse de réduction de la dépense
publique et de la dette
c'est possible à mes yeux à condition de
cesser de dire et enfin commencer à
faire
comment les Français peuvent-ils
comprendre que nous ayons la dépense
publique la plus élevée d'Europe
et des services publics qui se dégradent
sans cesse
Emmanuel Macron avait promis la
suppression de 120 000 postes de
fonctionnaires en 2017 il en aura créé
140 000 de plus de 6 ans voilà la
réalité
l'empilement de normes
coûte selon le rapport de l'OCDE 80
milliards d'euros par an à la France et
tout le monde paie les entreprises les
collectivités locales le contribuables
et il faudrait ajouter à cela le coût de
la suradeministration
rien que les collectivités locales
l'application des normes aura coûté 2
milliards d'euros de plus entre 2017 et
2021 il y a
1300 agences de l'État hors de tout
contrôle elles se sont progressivement
imposées comme des acteurs majeurs de la
sphère publique
chaque année elle coûte 64 milliards
d'euros au contribuable vous voyez que
la piste les économies existent et je
n'évoque pas la fraude sociale
ni l'aide médicale d'État qui a déposé
dépassé le milliard je pourrais
multiplier les exemples alors oui mes
chers amis
je le dis avec force combien de temps
encore
allons-nous contenter de dire et de ne
jamais faire
et que penser du climat social du climat
politique du climat de défiance et de
violence qui s'installent à tous les
étages de la société française je
voudrais m'y arrêter quelques instants
comment en est-on arrivé à ne plus
respecter
les chartes tricolores l'uniforme la
blouse blanche ou le maître toujours
plus d'agressions de policiers de
gendarmes de sapeurs-pompiers
1500 élus locaux agressés dans passé ils
enseignants qui déclarent de plus
pouvoir maintenir un minimum de
disciplines parmi leurs élèves les
services d'urgence de nos hôpitaux
contraint de recruter des agents de
sécurité moi comme Jérôme Fourquet et
Norbert Elias si le concept de
décibilisation
s'entend par le délitement de l'autorité
la montée des communautarismes et de la
violence la désintégration du vivre
ensemble et la faillite de l'école alors
oui je peux y adhérer
mes chers amis
[Applaudissements]
ces états généraux que nous lançons
aujourd'hui doivent être l'occasion de
définir une ligne politique pour notre
mouvement
je reste convaincu je vous le dis que la
bonne stratégie doit être l'indépendance
et la responsabilité
l'indépendance et la garantie de notre
légitimité la responsabilité et notre
boussole car pour nous seul l'intérêt de
la France doit guider nos choix
ce en même temps de gauche et de droite
a été mortifère pour notre démocratie
la vie politique a besoin de clarté les
Français ont besoin de repères
en tentant de désagréger
artificiellement les fondements de notre
système politique au fond 6 ans après
Emmanuel Macron a nourri les extrêmes à
droite comme à gauche il a appauvri le
débat jusqu'à la caricature une extrême
droite en quête de respectabilité qui
sort sur les échecs et les peurs une
extrême gauche qui rêve du Grand Soir
qui stérise la vie politique et qui en
vient même à vouloir définir selon ses
propres critères comme on l'a vu Annecy
qui mérite ou non d'être appelé un héros
je juste cela inacceptable
oui
indépendant nous restons une force libre
de nos mouvements et nos critiques de
nos accords comme de nos désaccords nous
restons une alternative crédible à cette
majorité du coût parcours sans méthode
sans cap sans vision alors je le dis
clairement cette majorité relative n'est
pas la nôtre nos différences sont très
profondes oui restons solides sur nos
appuis nous soutiendrons tout ce qui
sera
utile au redressement du pays dans la
clarté et sans compromission vous l'avez
compris je crois en l'avenir des
républicains pourvu que nous fassions
preuve d'unité et de cohésion unité
cohésion sur les idées mais aussi par
nos comportements
je crois à la force du maillage national
de nos élus locaux qui maintiennent la
cohésion du pays et assurons cher Bruno
je le pense chers collègues ici la
victoire de la majorité sénatoriale le
24 septembre prochain
aujourd'hui
nous engageons une reconstruction c'est
une oeuvre collective où le débat est
indispensable mais où la synthèse est
aussi une exigence
Éric ciotique mène ce travail avec
détermination nous sommes à ses côtés je
vous demande d'être à ses côtés pendant
cette période
nous avons un socle de valeur commune
nous croyons à une économie de marché de
la croissance de la responsabilité du
travail et de la compétitivité
il n'y a pas d'autre choix qu'une
société libérale à condition d'être
attentif à la nécessité du dialogue
social à l'indispensable solidarité
envers les plus démunis à la juste
répartition des ruchesses et à la
participation à laquelle nous devrons
donner plus de force et j'allais dire
plus de lisibilité moi je n'accepte pas
ces leçons de morale qui amènent une
lauréate du Festival de Cannes à fustigé
je la cite la marchandisation de la
culture que ce gouvernement néolibéral
oui que ce gouvernement néolibéral
défend et qui est en train de casser
l'exception culturelle française fin de
citation et au libéral la France
voyons le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire c'est 44% du PIB médaille
d'argent des pays développés et le taux
de dépenses publiques 58% médaille d'or
des pays développés la même lauréate qui
elle accepte le néolibéralisme quand il
lui permet de recevoir pour son œuvre
270 000 euros de la région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes et un million 200 millions
d'euros un million de d'euros de Canal+
le groupe de Monsieur Bolloré à
réfléchir par rapport à ces jugements
oui mes chers amis nous voulons une
écologie positive celle de la recherche
du progrès nous refusons l'écologie
punitive du renoncement et de la
désobéissance civile celle qui conduit
ce maraîcher de Loire-Atlantique à dire
la semaine passée je reprends ces mots
aujourd'hui je pleure les hadistes ont
détruit nos cerf en sol vivant et
culture sans pesticides en toute
impunité oui c'est cela
cette écologie positive
c'est l'inverse de celle de sainte
solide ou de Notre-Dame des Landes
celle de la décroissance qui ne se pose
pas la question de savoir pourquoi plus
de 6 millions de nos vélos sont apportés
du Cambodge du Vietnam ou de Chine
regardez la tête de carbone pour ceux
qui nous donnent facilement des leçons
après
21 lois en 20 ans sur l'immigration nous
n'en demandons qu'une enfin
utile et efficace et nous l'avons
proposé ensemble sénateurs et députés de
nos deux groupes et notre président
les flux migratoires ont atteint les
limites de l'acceptable pour nos
compatriotes la France ne peut plus être
la mieux disons de sociale de l'Europe
et nos capacités d'intégration sont
saturées et quel sinistre au fond de
vouloir disperser les migrants dans nos
départements pour cacher cette misère
que les Jeux Olympiques ne sont riens
alors
mes chers amis
écologie positive
avoir enfin une vraie politique
migratoire mais nous allons vivre aussi
une grave crise du logement
avec les nouvelles dispositions par
exemple sur les passoires thermiques
c'est plus de 2 millions de logements
qui seront concernés par l'interdiction
locative et prenne un logement sur deux
à Paris
par ailleurs d'ici deux ans avec les
zones affaiblission c'est plus de 13
millions d'automobilistes qui ne
pourraient plus entrer dans les grandes
villes merci à Philippe Tabarro d'avoir
ainsi souligné l'importance de ce
dossier oui tout cela m'apparaît une
assistance de une injustice de plus pour
cette France d'à côté celle de tous les
territoires qui n'a plus accès de
manière satisfaisante aux soins à
l'éducation et au service public
enfin il est temps que l'école retrouve
sa vocation première la transmission des
savoirs une école où le maître est
respecté ou le principe de laïcité
s'impose à tous sans faiblesse et dans
la clarté
alors mes chers amis puisque
Geoffroy Didier va présenter par une
sage
je vous demande d'être non pas
simplement sage mais déterminer
renforçons notre unité
construisons un projet ambitieux un
projet de vérité qui répond aux attentes
de nos compatriotes mais qui regardent
dans les yeux les réalités de notre pays
un projet de redressement qui correspond
à nos valeurs et porte une espérance
nous avons et nous aurons de nombreux
talents pour le porter et c'est une
chance mais la priorité c'est d'abord de
retrouver la confiance des Français et
de leur proposer un projet
oui
ne vous laissez pas détourner une autre
objectif par une certaine bien-pensance
qui nous a conduit à l'échec nous
craignons pas de dire la vérité même si
elle dérange ne reculons pas devant
l'obstacle
ne plions pas devant le jugement de ces
élites qui pensent toujours avoir raison
mais qui en fait ont été des jugés par
l'histoire soyons nous-mêmes avec nos
convictions que nous devons assumer
porter haut et fort et retrouver
l'indispensable proximité avec nos
concitoyens oui mes chers amis
cet après-midi je serai à Londres pour
honorer la mémoire de ceux et le jean
Moulin qui se sont dressés pour que
l'emporte les idéaux de justice et de
liberté est une certaine idée de la
France car en juin 40
c'est à Londres homstett que se trouvait
l'espérance des femmes et des hommes
esprits de liberté parce que notre
famille politique dans sa diversité et
aussi profondément inspiré par cet
héritage gaulliste alors inspirons-nous
de cet héritage soyons debout soyons
volontaires et préparant préparant le
renouveau des républicains pour que vive
la république et que vive la France
[Musique]